20 years after the united states ejected
the taliban from power they have
returned to kabul and are in charge of
afghanistan over the spring and summer
the insurgents made quick work sweeping
across the country sometimes seizing as
many as half a dozen cities in one week
the new rulers appear content with
grabbing control and say they do not
have plans for any violent and chaotic
sacking of the city
for now the streets of kabul are
relatively calm and quiet save what
we've seen from the airport the taliban
appears to want an orderly takeover not
a messy transition
that's exactly what afghanistan's
neighbors want too they are watching
very closely with china saying it is
ready for quote friendly relations here
are comments from both pakistan's
foreign minister and from china's
special envoy for afghan affairs
this situation the situation is fluid
it's evolving
in this situation we have to talk and
play our role very responsibly
god willing pakistan's role will be
positive
we have clearly said that we have not
intervened in their internal matters
nor do we have any such intentions
we do not have any favorites in
afghanistan
afghan people have to decide about their
future
whether it's afghan taliban
or afghan rulers
also need to make sure that the chaos
will not spill over into other countries
china in particular has a 90 kilometer
borderline with afghanistan and they are
our neighbours
so we hope that afghanistan can achieve
peace and reconciliation as soon as
possible and stop the chaos and prevent
the threat of terrorism from spilling
over into neighbouring countries peace
tranquility and security must be
maintained
we have andrew small with us to talk
about the regional implications of the
taliban takeover he's senior
transatlantic fellow at the german
marshall fund of the united states
andrew welcome to the program
thanks for having me on
now we have pakistan and china both
clearly nervous about developments they
keep talking about peace
it seems like the american and nato
presence all these years did buy that
kind of security for these two countries
from china's perspective the u.s
security presence was kind of the lesser
of two evils they were concerned about a
large-scale u.s military presence in
their backyard but they saw the benefits
that particularly the kind of slimmed
down version had when it came to
containing instability in the region and
also going after specific terrorist
concerns that that china had in
afghanistan and some of the pakistani
border areas as well they did ultimately
want to see the us withdraw but they
wanted to see the u.s only stepping out
at a point in which a political
settlement had been reached for pakistan
it's it's a more mixed picture i i think
but but they too will be concerned and
are concerned about the immediate
spillover effects of what's happening
even though of course this is the policy
they've backed they've supported the
taliban for some time
pakistan has been the rear operating
base so this this outcome is something
that in a very different way from china
they they really own
now i want to actually uh jump on that
you mentioned pakistan being a safe
haven for the taliban for the last 20
years and critics including a number of
western countries have accused islamabad
of outright supporting the taliban
that's very confusing because they're
worried about the refugees what does
pakistan want here
i mean they are concerned about the
refugees there is a different quality of
relationship with with the taliban now
versus when the pakistan was kind of
first backing their their rise to power
in particular the rise of insurgent
groups like the the pakistani taliban
the ttp in pakistan itself
have changed the balance of concerns
they now the pakistanis also don't want
afghanistan used as a rear operating
base by the pakistani taliban to conduct
attacks on their territory and they have
hosted large number of large numbers of
refugees for many years millions of
afghan refugees they will be concerned
about the considerable numbers that
they're expecting to to flow to their
borders
that's very interesting now let's pivot
to china
you mentioned this earlier about its
fears uh in regards to terrorism it
shares a border with afghanistan
something a lot of people don't know and
of course beijing claims there's an
insurgency within its own borders
with
uyghur separatists and this has given
china the excuse to build hundreds of
camps and intern over a million ethnic
minorities so what is china thinking and
calculating now in regards to that
well
the uyghur question has really been the
standing issue between china and the
taliban going all the way back to the
time that mullah omar and taliban were
were lost in power in
afghanistan at the turn of the
millennium the late 90s the main issue
between them was always the question of
whether there were uyghurs uh what china
then called and still calls etim
being hosted in various ways by by the
taliban on on the territory that they
control if you look at the meeting that
took place between wangi and mula
baradar recently if you look down the
the readout of the meeting it's the same
issues being raised two decades later
it's still about the relationship that
the taliban have with uiga groups which
which again china is still calling etim
but i think it is clear that there have
been turkistan islamic party fighters in
afghanistan so this isn't
as it was i think at certain points in
the past a kind of completely fictitious
immaterial concern just designed as an
excuse to justify what china's doing in
xinjiang there is a real
counter-terrorism concern that china has
in afghanistan at the same time and
there are also wider groups operating
there that have made china target in a
way that they they hadn't even a couple
of decades ago and
what china expects of course of its
neighboring countries if it's the
pakistanis or the central asians is that
uyghurs are killed or handed over or
expelled from the country or
similarly drastic measures that's not
something the taliban have ever been
willing to do
so the demands that china's going to
have in this regard when it comes to a
taliban government and the demands
they've always had of the taliban i
think there's there is this bar that
they're not sure that the taliban are
willing to reach so it is going to be a
question that's that's likely to be a
standing tension between the two sides
got it now
let's take a step back this is not a
great moment for the united states this
is humiliating frankly
and um i want to ask what other
countries in the region including
military allies such as south korea or
the philippines might be thinking about
this or or japan or taiwan take your
pick what is the message they're getting
here
i think you have to separate the policy
itself from the way it was executed i
think
the purpose of withdrawing from
afghanistan and to a certain extent over
a longer arc the drawdown from the
middle east was to refocus on the
indo-pacific on the maritime space on
backing allies and partners in the wider
region i think that seemed to be the
bigger and more important strategic game
so the principle that the us should not
be stuck making vast commitments to land
wars in eurasia and should be refocusing
on the indo-pacific
in some ways that shift that pivot that
rebalancing is something that allies in
the region wanted to see i think the
concern is rather the manner in which
this was was executed whatever you
attribute the the failures to um the
intelligence analysis in terms of the
speed that it took place
what seems to be the poor planning the
whole manner in which it's conducted is
clearly going to be a matter of concern
to uh to to to allies in the asia
pacific um and in the immediate region
the spillover effects uh have direct
repercussions
andrew small thank you so much for
joining us
sure very happy today